joining me now here on the phone on the
Rich Eisen show is the man himself of
the mmqb calm he is none other than Hall
of Famer Peter King how are you Peter
what's that breach how you doing I am
fine i'm here i'm smelling the fresh cut
grass it is all good as I'm sitting here
on the field in Denver and a beautiful
day the the entire sky is clear it's
going to be a perfect night for football
you made quite the case in the mmqb calm
this week that Peyton Manning could be a
better version of himself here than he
was in Indianapolis what what makes you
think that well I mean I've never been
the biggest fan of quarterback rating of
passer rating but he is 17 points better
as a Bronco than he was as a cult and
you know I had a bunch of people say
we'll wait a second let's let's
eliminate his first year or two or three
when he was still finding his way what
has it been like apples to apples so
then I compared the last three years in
Indianapolis when he was at his peak to
the first three years in Denver and he's
still 15 quarterback rating points
higher now I asked them about this
sunday night after the game and he said
you know I really don't know but I said
I like my gut feeling is it probably has
something to do with the fact that my
mechanics I went back to ground zero and
I started a brand new basically I
started a brand new way with with David
Cutcliffe I just went back to the
beginning and I built my throwing motion
built all of that all over again so I
wouldn't have any bad habits at all and
but I really think it's more than that
rich I just think that you know his is
five receivers that he has right now
that he works with and i'll even include
Andre Caldwell is number six because I
think he's good to his five receivers in
Denver right now I just think are better
than any combination similar combination
that he ever had in Indianapolis now
edgerrin james who was better than any
back he's had in Denver but is it just
the receivers themselves again as much
as you love Dallas Clark and what a
security blanket he was Julius Thomas is
just a different player he's very good
intermediate but he also can get down
the field as well as any tight end and
football right now so I just think his
talent that he's playing with right now
is is probably better than it was an
indie and obviously this year this
particular year he certainly I'm sure
being helped by some of the rules that
had cut out some of that you know that
chicken fighting down field between
receivers and defensive back yeah yeah
anytime on the phone with Peter King
right now on Peter you do realize that
this discussion really gets under the
skin of people in Indianapolis where he
won a championship he is not 11 here in
Denver and that usually is the metric
that decides all and then there are some
people in Seattle that think how could
you say he's better when we exposed him
and the Broncos in a manner that few
teams are have been able to do I'm sure
you're aware certainly on your Twitter
feed that this Dixon's have caused this
this entire conversation there's no
doubt about it in most people who and
rightfully so I mean you know to be the
clear-cut best quarterback of all time
he's going to have to do better and do
more in the playoffs then he has to this
point we all know that but I'm just
simply trying to say that we're seeing a
38 year old man play the position as
well right now anyway in my opinion play
the position as well as it's been played
and you know you can't deny that you
know he he played one of the best
defenses in football on Sunday night
anyporn into tatters and so you can I
totally understand people who say he was
at his best in Indianapolis and say he
hasn't one of the odd it
got it but to deny his brilliance to
deny his greatness now is I think it's
just wrong dad open and then and it's
just an interesting how the colts fans
are are upset about this even though
they have a dream come true again at the
position I mean Andrew Luck is the dream
true he is no question of franchise
quarterback he could even be the MVP of
the league right now Peter do you think
about it yeah I think you're going to
see what a two candidates tonight in
philip rivers and peyton manning but
luck also especially with the way they
have turned their season around in a
plate so great the last five weeks in
indianapolis so I mean those three would
be candidates rich I wrote a little bit
about this last week about JJ Watt that
basically it's been 17 years since a
player without double-digit wins on a
team of double-digit wins has won an MVP
and it's been 28 years since a defensive
player won the MVP so you put those two
together and I guess what I would say is
the Houston Texans better make the
playoffs for JK want to have a chance
and he better keep you know being
lawrence taylor lake in his play for him
to have a chance yeah so tonight what do
you think happens when toe meets ball
between these two teams that and the
charges as i mentioned at the top of the
show at five and 14 days ago to lose two
games in division within a span of four
days to fall to five and three when
every other division leader is 5 and 2
this is a massive game for San Diego
tonight Peter agreed I mean Adam
Schefter had a great tweet this morning
I thought rich where he said that San
Diego and you got to give great credit
to John Pagano their defensive
coordinator that they helped Denver to
in the two games to an average
possession time with 21 minutes and 34
seconds which
I mean you might say well okay what
what's the big dealer the big deal is
they were getting off the field against
the Denver Broncos last year and they
were also able to have some long drives
and I think one of the things the reason
why it won't be 21 34 tonight my opinion
is that Denver's defense is
significantly better you know I think
the addition of both a keen to leave
something you know basically used to
replace Dominique rodgers-cromartie and
added a real physical element to the
secondary along with TJ Ward Chris
Harris being back he was hurt last year
in the playoffs against San Diego and
then I think the other the other thing
that really has made a huge difference
both on and off the field is the Marcus
where his influence on von Miller and
his influence on offensive game plans so
I don't think that San Diego is going to
have as much success with long sustained
drives this year they did in the two
games last year yeah and last year Peter
they were those long sustained drives
were not ended with settled field goals
they were they were they put it in the
end zone they jammed it in the end zone
every single time they had a chain right
and and that was the difference-maker
too I think so and I think one of the
other things to look at in this game
tonight I mean the one thing that if you
could describe sort of you know a
quarterback as you know a big game
quarterback wherever the game is I'm
beginning to think more and more about
philip rivers in that way you know last
year in Cincinnati in the playoffs even
though there they had a lot of health
community dolphin that day I mean that
was a great game of Thursday night game
in denver last year a really important
game to their playoff hopes rivers was
so good he's been so good so far this
year you know you hate to sort of put
the jinx on him but I think that Mike
McCoy has done such a good job
in taking Philip Rivers to that next
level where he's ten percent better he's
protecting the ball a little bit more
he's not taking the same kind of chances
that he did in his last couple years
with Norv Turner and now even without
Ken Whisenhunt you can tell he's really
bonded with Frank Wright and that he
really likes working with right I've
always thought that right was one of the
smartest quarterbacks I ever dealt with
in my ears covering football and it
really shows in how he's helped rivers
get even better this year yeah and of
course Mike McCoy taken from the
sidelines here in Denver and he's been
phenomenal I mean that this is a bona
fide playoff team you know last year
they had to they had a win their last
four in a row to make the playoffs and
won a playoff game and part of that run
was that Thursday night game that you
you were referring to here but this is a
bona fide playoff team now Peter there's
no question about it when you think
about it I and I think rich one of the
reasons is Tom so let's go the general
manager has really hit the ground
running in the last couple of years he's
added some key guys you know AJ Smith
last couple of drafts they've also got
you know coral eejit it you know led by
him they've added some guys I mean
Melvin Ingram's and hurt a little bit
too much but I think the young players
on defense you know are really starting
to pay off for them and even though
they've also nick hardwick on the
offensive lines of the year i think
they've done a good job in sort of
building a little bit of a fortress
around rivers and you know obviously
this running back who has totally come
out of nowhere those are the kind of
reasons why I mean we I was in the Hall
of Fame the contributors Hall of Fame
discussion yesterday and when I look at
Bill Poland's track record when I look
at Ron Wolf's track record those are the
two guys who got in they were always
really really good in the middle and
late rounds they'd always find players
and in undrafted free agency and that's
one of the things that I think Tom
telesco took from Bill Polian you know
that 178 pick can be is important
as the 17th pick yeah and tonight we're
going to see Brandon Oliver the
so-called third string running back
who's been running like a first-string
ever since he had the opportunity a few
weeks ago that's going to be a crucial
component to tonight's Thursday night
game Peter thanks for calling in again
we've been on three weeks you've
appeared now twice I hope to have you on
a third time very short order thank you
very much rich have a great night the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience